hi Jen
chai yeah hi dad hello Chad indeed et
has exclusively obtained some seriously
steamy pics of the 28 year old
bachelorette contestant from a recent
photo shoot in Tulsa Oklahoma
proving all that working out has 100%
paid off
Chad channeled his days as a Marine in
these shirtless snaps flexing his
insanely chiseled abs wearing camouflage
pants and combat boots then he went more
relaxed swapping army fatigues for khaki
shorts let's be real though the outfit
doesn't matter we're still fixated on
that 12-pack showing off his versatility
look Chad can also do sultry and serious
he rocked a gray suit and a black vest
while lighting up a cigar which makes
sense because you know chad is pretty
hot I'm like manlier more rugged version
of Bennett the luxury real estate agent
is being called the villain of the
season he's had no shortage of issues
with the other guys you're a whiny
little [ __ ] we like you go to burn
don't you touch me dude you're gonna die
he was recently on set with the
Bachelorette herself
Jojo Fletcher where she gushed over all
her male suitors
I feel more lucky than ever after today
these guys are so unbelievable and
they're so kind I feel so lucky